internation thank you so much for  listening to the plane project this uh I  just want to give a huge shout out to  serendipity if the Wi-Fi was not broken  on my flight from Sweden to New York  this would have never happened kind of  just got my work done sat and just  started thinking and somehow got  ridiculously inspired please bear with  me with the quality of the audio  obviously I was in the air and in that  zone I hope you enjoy this kind of a new  kind of project concept just a kind of a  goal most like a rant an album I'm very  proud of it I have a funny feeling a lot  of you will get tremendous value out of  it and for somebody's and I was able to  dig a little deeper than normal with a  lot of the content and I would love to  know which one of your which one was  your favorite rant enjoy this enjoy this  enjoy this see ya